Bon bah voilà ben j'vous laisse visiter !
C'est pas mal, c'est pas mal.
Sauf euh... le truc, là, au millieu du salon.
Ah oui !
Ouais... Ouais enfin, ça on peut changer. On peut changer la déco ?
Ah oui bien sûr ! Aucun problème, oui oui vous faites ce que vous voulez !
Ouais bon bah voilà tu vois, c'est bien,
on pourra enlever le monsieur pendu au milieu de la pièce, c'est pas grave.
Pourquoi vous voulez faire ça ?
Bah nan...
Bah parce que c'est un monsieur pendu au milieu du salon.
Qu'est-ce qu'on...?
On peut pas vraiment pas l'enlever ?
Ah non je suis désolé, la propriétaire a été très stricte à ce sujet.
On touche ni au monsieur pendu de la salle principale, ni au mini-frigo de la kitchenette, je peux rien faire.
Oui, y'a un mini-frigo dans la kitchenette...?
Oui mais il a de la merde qui coule de ses chaussures...
Effectivement, au moment du décès les sphincters se relâchent
alors du coup bah ça fait une espèce de petite flaque en dessous...
Mais vous savez, c'est du lino alors...
Ça voilà, ça... c'est du lino.
J'peux... passer un coup de serpillière.
Écoutez, au risque de vous paraître un poil brutal,
il y a un autre couple qui est prêt à signer dès demain matin, alors...
Ben non mais écoutez voilà... On va pas le prendre parce que j'pense qu'il y a pas de...
Tututututu...! Seulement 900 € par mois.
Mmmmh ouais... On l'prend, on l'prend ?
Allez, on le prend !
Aaah vous faites une très très belle affaire messieurs, bravo !
Bon bah voilà bah j'vous laisse un petit peu... un petit peu visiter !
Moi y'a que... ça, qui me chagrine un petit peu, en fait.
Suricate